grace everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where it has apparently been
told to me that Nintendo switch game
cartridges taste bad so the logic behind
this is that Nintendo doesn't want kids
to eat the game cartridges they are very
very small let me pull one out for you
it's pretty tiny so to prevent children
from wanting to swallow things because
apparently children like swallowing
small things just in general
Nintendo specifically manufactured each
game cartridge to taste terrible so that
kids wouldn't want to do that so I am
testing it for you right now The Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild is I think
one of the best games I've ever played
but what better way to test my love then
to lick it does it really taste as bad
as they say let's find out The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild ten out of ten
from edge magazine but how does it taste
did they review that let's do it I'm
going to lick the stick up on the front
I'm not going to put the whole thing in
my mouth because that would be awful
oh it's so oh god it's so awful
oh so I feel like I didn't look at that
much of it and it overtook my entire
mouth it's so you know it feels like
I've had like an electricity burn across
with terrible alcohol on the a section
of my tongue I doesn't it didn't hurt or
anything but man that tastes terrible
yeah zero out of ten The Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild tastes like nothing
else I've ever tasted it's like an
electrical fire came into my mouth but
got rid of the fire pod it's like if you
combined rusty metal with battery acid I
think it's going away now I think it's
finally fading how do I get rid of this
terrible taste a review on do I think
that it will sell children from eating
video game cartridges I don't know I
didn't know that was a problem with the
3ds I wouldn't eat it as soon as it
touched my tongue it tasted look I'm
gonna just put the smallest amount on my
tongue and see if it still tastes bad
all right let's still [ __ ] awful holy
[ __ ]
what manner of sorcery is this look
really I love this game this one ship
has brought me so much joy but it really
does taste like the literal devil well
that's it for me today you guys it is
taste test of The Legend of Zelda breath
of the wild I know that you were all
really excited to hear my review of how
it tastes
the verdict is zero out of 10 it tastes
truly awful I would not recommend
licking any Nintendo switch titles it's
just the was if you have kids then it's
10 out of 10 because they probably won't
eat your game so that's good but the
people who are just hungry in general
probably not as exciting